[MUSIC PLAYING]
MIHAI IONESCU: Hello,
and welcome
again to Payments Live.
My name is Mihai, and with me
today I have my colleagues
Peng on the left, and on my
right is my colleague Nasir.
PENG YING: It's good
to be back.
MIHAI IONESCU: And I guess
everyone is really excited
because today we have
a fabulous topic.
And that is a recap of the
Google Wallet announcements
and product launches at Google
I/O. So this year's I/O was
one of the best for
the Wallet team.
Besides meeting all kinds of
developers and getting
valuable feedback, we had some
very interesting sessions and
product launches.
And we had thousands of people
watching our sessions and
interacting with us in the
Developer Sandbox.
So let's get right into it.
What did we announce
at Google I/O?
And I'll switch.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
MIHAI IONESCU: Hello, everyone,
and welcome again to
Payments Live.
My name is Mihai, and with me
today I have my colleague Peng
on the left, and on the right
is my colleague Nasir.
NASIR KHAN: Hi.
MIHAI IONESCU: And everyone is
really excited today because
we have a fabulous topic.
And that is a recap of the
announcements and Google
Wallet product launches at I/O.
And this year's I/O was
one of the best for
the Wallet team.
Besides major product
announcements and meeting lots
of developers, getting valuable
feedback, we had some
very interesting sessions.
And thousands of people watched
our sessions and
visited our Developer Sandbox,
where we interacted with the
Wallet team.
So let's get straight into it.
What did we announce?
Let me switch to my slides here,
where we have the list
of sessions.
And we had two major
themes this year.
And the first one was around
improving the purchase
experience in a mobile world.
More and more purchases are
happening on smartphones and
on tablets.
And there are some serious
improvements that can be made
around the purchasing
experience.
And for this, we had two
interesting sessions.
The first one was "Selling
Physical Goods on Android with
Google Instant Buy." And the
second was "Building
Compelling mCommerce Experiences
on Android." And
I'll briefly talk with Nasir
about what we did to improve
the customer experience there.
And the second theme, which
Peng will go into in more
detail, was around digitizing
the entire information that
you have in your physical wallet
and move it to your--
PENG YING: Cloud wallet.
MIHAI IONESCU: Cloud wallet.
PENG YING: Google Wallet.
MIHAI IONESCU: Digital wallet.
And again, two great
sessions here.
The first one was "Digitizing
the Entire Wallet, Introducing
Wallet Objects," which
is our new API.
And the second one, which goes
into a little bit more detail,
is "Redefining Loyalty in the
Mobile Age." And, of course,
we also announced a very
interesting product, which was
Pay by Gmail.
And we didn't have a session
for it, but it was very
popular with the I/O crowd and
all the attendees who got to
send money to each other.
PENG YING: I think we gave
everybody $10 as well.
MIHAI IONESCU: We
gave everybody--
PENG YING: That usually helps.
MIHAI IONESCU: It is still
rolling out to all the Gmail
users in the US.
But you can also get earlier
access if you have friends who
already have it.
Or if you know anyone who
attended Google I/O, just ask
them for money.
[INAUDIBLE].
They can give a few
dollars to you.
So let's go through the
sessions one by one.
Let's start with the Instant
Buy session.
So Nasir, we announced Google
Wallet Instant Buy.
NASIR KHAN: Yes.
MIHAI IONESCU: For Android,
which is a pretty significant
announcement.
And can you go into
more details, tell
us more about it?
NASIR KHAN: Absolutely,
I'd love to.
So as you said, this
is an Android API.
This is actually an Android API
for physical goods which
was recently announced on May
15 on day one of I/O. And we
also had this session that you
talked about that Prakash and
Michael Galpin from
engineering--
Prakash is our PM, and Michael
Galpin, who is our tech lead,
they presented.
So it was a very interesting
session.
They actually covered
their entire
product in great detail.
And I wanted to give you a quick
overview of what the
session was all about.
The most interesting piece of
information that comes out of
the first few slides of the
session was this number, 97%.
This is the rate of abandonment
on mobile devices
for any purchase.
Now why this happens,
they went into
detail of why this happens.
As you know, form factors
play a big role.
You have to enter a lot of
details while you are
purchasing things.
And people just can't do
it on a small device.
They just either are moving
fast, and it's really painful
to enter your name, address,
shipping address, billing
address, credit card
information, and so forth.
And this is where this
product comes in.
So essentially, what was
launched here is this Instant
Buy, which is basically an API
that enables fast checkout for
physical goods on the device.
It's a native API which works
from within the native app for
merchants, and so users don't
have to go out at all from
their app experience.
You just skip the registraion
and sign-in, and essentially,
you're already signed in
to an Android device.
Because once you have an account
on an Android device,
you're already signed in.
It's extremely secure.
So from the user perspective,
they get all the benefits that
they have using Wallet.
The merchants get the complete
payment flow as they would get
the flow with any other
payment instrument.
But essentially, with Wallet,
they get what we call a
one-time-use card.
So the user is protected by the
amount that they actually
purchased with the merchant.
And the merchant gets a pretty
seamless experience, which is
the other beauty of it.
Because the integration
is extremely simple.
It's almost zero changes to
their back end, really.
And best of all, it's
free from Google.
So Google doesn't charge
any additional
fee for this product.
So from a merchant's
perspective, it's like any
other credit card coming
into their flow.
MIHAI IONESCU: Yeah, so you
get best of both worlds.
NASIR KHAN: Exactly.
So let me now go into it
a little bit more.
So they also announced 11
merchants that went live on
the same day.
MIHAI IONESCU: I see some
pretty big names here.
NASIR KHAN: Pretty
big names here.
As you can see, they are from
a wide array of verticals.
We have travel, Priceline,
Expedia, Airbnb.
We have some overhead kind
of merchants like
Tabbedout and GoPago.
If you have traveled in a big
city, you're taking a cab, you
must be familiar with Uber,
which is a pretty nice
experience.
So all of these were launched
on that day, and pretty
significant.
We're seeing a great update
on new apps ever since.
But let me give you a little bit
more insight of what this
product is all about.
So, like I said, a native app,
from the user perspective when
they are interacting with it,
from within the app, they get
to access their Google
Wallet in the cloud.
And the way it happens
seamlessly is the app accesses--
and I'll come to it in a
minute about what the
architecture looks like.
But essentially, from the user
perspective, they don't move
out of the app at all.
They access their Google Wallet
securely, and from
there, they can select the
instrument of their choice and
the shipping address
of their choice.
And the information comes back
to the app, which can then be
passed on to the merchant's
payment
processor in the cloud.
So it's a pretty
seamless flow.
So users just interact
with Wallet once.
Merchants get what we call a
one-time or a proxy card.
And then they use that proxy
card as they would use any
other card with their payment
processor in the cloud.
So pretty seamless and nice
experience for both the
merchant and the user.
MIHAI IONESCU: Yeah, I like it
that we started the design
with the user in mind.
Make it as seamless as possible
for the user.
Keep in mind the restrictions
of mobile devices, limited
screen size.
And then as seamless
as possible for
the merchant as well.
Give them a card.
They'll charge it.
They're done.
Very nice.
NASIR KHAN: And going back to
the number that I started
with, 97%, this actually, as
you'll see, we have a demo
actually for you that will show
you as to how this really
reduces that friction.
But before that, let me just
show you a quick high-level
architecture of this solution.
So how does this fit in from
a developer perspective?
So if you are familiar with
Google Play Services, this is
part of Google Play Services.
And the way it works is that
your app actually compiles in
a very thin client library,
which is the Google Play
Services client library.
And then there is a Google Play
Services APK which runs
on the device, which essentially
is a window into
all Google services
on the device.
So your app interacts with this
thin client library and
gets access to Wallet.
The beauty of this is the Google
Play Services APK has
an automatic update from Google
Play Store, so you
don't have to worry about any
changes or answers that you
make from a merchant
perspective.
And the users keep on getting
the best user experience
without them having
to do anything
specific in terms of updating.
So like I said, we have a
demo lined up for you.
Let me just show you a quick
demo just so that you can see
what I'm talking about here
in [? full glory. ?]
So if you can see my device
now, I have this demo
application.
This demo application
is selling cameras.
And I just have three
demo cameras here.
So it's a typical mobile
app with an
mCommerce kind of a store.
So I select a camera, as you
would do in any other merchant
app, and I add it to my cart.
Now something interesting
happened.
As you can see, there is a Buy
with Google button here.
And the Buy with Google button
is where you actually begin to
interact with Google Wallet.
So on this page, instead of
clicking Continue Checkout,
which I would do otherwise,
I would
click on Buy with Google.
And this brings a very
interesting UI, which is
actually a Google Wallet UI.
So as you can see, I didn't move
out of the app, but this
UI pops up right
within the app.
And it is actually leading
me into my Google
Wallet in the cloud.
So it shows me my saved
payment instruments.
I select a MasterCard here.
And it also shows some addresses
that I have.
So I select this address
on file.
And this check box is basically
for using Google
Wallet for future purchases.
And that's going to be a
pre-authorization, where
actually if you select
this, you don't
see this pop up again.
So it just assumes your
intention to use Google Wallet
next time around.
For now, I'll uncheck it
and move to Continue.
And as you can see, I'm right
on to the confirmation page.
At this time, I have gotten my
what you call a mass payment
instrument, my MasterCard,
right here.
I have my shipping address.
I can, of course, change
any of these.
I have a Change button,
which brings the
same chooser as before.
But essentially, I'll
not do that.
I'll just confirm the order.
And that's it.
The payment is done.
The payment information has
gone to the merchant.
And as you can see, I didn't
have to enter any of the
things, my credit card,
address, any of that.
So it's extremely, extremely
simple for the user.
Just a few clicks
and you're done.
MIHAI IONESCU: Yeah.
Two-click buying experience.
You like the camera?
Buy with Google--
NASIR KHAN: It's being
shipped right now.
I'll tell you how it is.
MIHAI IONESCU: And you're out
of a few hundred dollars,
probably close to $1,000 for
a good, quality camera.
NASIR KHAN: Exactly.
MIHAI IONESCU: Great.
Thank you.
Thank you for the demo, Nasir.
And quick question.
So this is an Android
API, specifically
an Android SDK API.
And we already have an Android
in-app billing API, which also
is a Wallet API.
How do these two APIs compare
to each other?
NASIR KHAN: That's a
very good question.
So the in-app billing API,
as you know, has been
around for a while.
And that's the API for digital
goods being sold on Android.
Whereas this API is specifically
for physical
goods and services.
So it's a clear distinction.
They're two different APIs, but
between the two of them,
they cover the entire
spectrum.
MIHAI IONESCU: So we added
what was missing.
NASIR KHAN: Exactly.
MIHAI IONESCU: We had digital
goods used by thousands of
developers.
And now services and physical
goods are also taking off in
the mobile world.
And we have the API for you.
NASIR KHAN: And from the user
perspective, it's the same
Wallet in the cloud.
So from user, it's
pretty similar.
MIHAI IONESCU: Yeah, for the
user, they're using the same
account, the same Wallet.
That's good for the users.
How about the developers
and the merchants?
How can they use it?
Where can they get their
hands on the SDK?
NASIR KHAN: Absolutely.
So as of this time, this
is still a limited
availability API.
We do have an interest form, as
you can see on the screen.
MIHAI IONESCU: You
can sign up.
NASIR KHAN: It's a URL here,
getinstantbuy.withgoogle.com.
So it's an interest form.
MIHAI IONESCU: So if
everyone can see
it, it's on our slides.
NASIR KHAN: Yes, fill
it up, and somebody
will get back to you.
MIHAI IONESCU: Easy
to remember.
Getinstantbuy.withgoogle.com.
Easy form.
It will ask you for some
information to get an idea of
what kind of card processing
you have and what type of
services and products
you're selling.
And once you sign up, we'll
get in touch with you.
So this was our main session
on the Instant Buy API.
And I encourage everyone,
if you didn't see the
session, go see it.
We have a lot more information,
some interesting
demos with some partners,
and you'll learn a
lot from that session.
So there's another session
that was also very
interesting.
And that's the "Building
mCommerce Experiences on
Android." Can you tell us a
little bit about this session?
NASIR KHAN: Yes.
This is a very interesting
session.
This is actually a pretty
deep Android session.
So as you see in this demo that
the Google Wallet team
has embraced our best practices
and seamlessly given
them to the user and merchant
for them to use.
This session talks a little
bit about those.
How they did what they did,
and also how merchants can
make use of those best practices
in their apps to
provide a seamless, nice
experience for the user.
So this was a bunch of best
practices and tips and tricks.
I've just taken a few of them.
It's a very in-depth,
nice session.
I encourage everybody
to do this as well.
But in terms of key takeaways,
as you can see in mobile, like
we talk about form filling
is a big problem.
So they could talk about how
they can do real-time
formatting of forms, how they
can do validation of the form
right within the device, how
they can auto-advance fields
so know when the field is filled
up, and you move to the
next one, making it easy for
the user to navigate.
Input suggestions for
different things.
And what I really like is
address autocomplete.
I'll have another
slide on that.
Disk-based cache for quick
access of things which are not
changing so frequently.
So they talk about selectively
caching things.
There's a very insightful
discussion about security and
privacy as well in the talk.
But what I really like, as I
said, is address autocomplete.
It's a beautiful experience if
you happen to use any of these
apps, button apps, you'll
see if you have
an address in Wallet.
So you can do that very quickly
because it just
happens automatically.
Just start entering it.
And just like as you would have
on Maps, it would get the
information from Wallet, from
Google Places, and have the
addresses right there,
which you can see.
MIHAI IONESCU: I love
this new feature.
Sometimes I even forget
the address.
But when I see it poking
out in the
drop-down, oh, I remember.
That's the address, yeah.
NASIR KHAN: Yeah, so that
was the session.
MIHAI IONESCU: Awesome.
So very, very technical session,
but definitely
everyone will find
it interesting.
And it applies to all kinds of
mCommerce applications, not
necessarily Wallet.
So have a look at it.
But are there any real-world
examples that people can go
and try and see how the
API works and have a
feel of the Buy flow?
NASIR KHAN: Oh, absolutely.
So we had the partner
that we launched.
MIHAI IONESCU: You showed
us the list of partners.
NASIR KHAN: Yeah.
So all of the partners have
done a very good job of
integrating our API.
MIHAI IONESCU: Shall we
go back to the list?
NASIR KHAN: Yeah, let's look
at the list one more time.
MIHAI IONESCU: All right.
Here's the list.
NASIR KHAN: Yeah.
So I would recommend all of
you to go ahead, download
these apps, and play
around with them.
In terms of best practices, like
I said, all of them have
done a great job.
But you can have a look at
Fancy because the Fancy
engineer was also co-hosting
the session that I talked
about, so he was there.
And they talked about some of
the best practices that they
had in their app.
Like, for example, how
do they handle an
international audience.
How did they handle
internationalization,
localization, things of that
kind, which are extremely
important for mobile as well
because if you move to UK, you
have a different kind
of postal code.
So you have to take that
into account and
things of that kind.
Latency improvements, how the
apps can do well on latency
reductions.
Fancy has also done a good job
of integrating Wallet and G+.
So that's a really interesting
demo, as you'll see.
[INAUDIBLE] is another
interesting app.
They have what we call a
two-click purchase, a single
SKU purchase.
So have a look at that.
They are following Android
UI guidelines very, very
carefully, so it's a
good UI to look at.
Expedia is a fluid
user experience.
It's a very beautiful app.
They load a lot of things
in background.
The Wallet information they
load in the background.
They have something called swipe
to purchase, which works
beautifully.
Priceline is, again, a very
nice integration.
They have also done SSO,
Single Sign-On,
so that works nicely.
They have a simplified
checkout with Wallet.
And they are basically, if you
want to look at a standard
Wallet checkout flow,
Priceline is
the app to look at.
It's very similar in terms of
the flow through the app that
I showed you.
So it's basically following
exactly the kind of flow that
we recommend.
Yeah, so all of these
apps are great.
MIHAI IONESCU: Fantastic.
So we have the API launched.
We have some great examples and
partners to inspire from.
We have some great sessions
that go deep into details.
And they introduce some new
additions to the Android
world, like autocomplete
and all that stuff.
So get ready to implement.
Start selling.
PENG YING: Get ready to sell.
MIHAI IONESCU: Instant Buy,
get ready to sell.
NASIR KHAN: Get Instant Buy.
MIHAI IONESCU: So remember,
getinstantbuy.withgoogle.com.
Sign up.
And documentation is out,
examples are out.
You just need to have
something to sell.
Great.
Thank you, Nasir.
Very interesting couple
of sessions.
So now going back to our list,
the second major theme.
And now Peng will take over.
PENG YING: Yeah, this
is my turn.
MIHAI IONESCU: And we're going
to talk about Wallet Objects
and digitizing your entire
Wallet experience.
So can you tell us a little bit
more about Wallet Objects
platform and what exactly
did we announce at I/O?
PENG YING: Sure.
So I'm sure some of you are
already familiar with what
Google Wallet is, we call
it Google Wallet.
And for those of you who aren't,
it's Google's goal--
well, the idea is that with
Google Wallet, what we want to
do is we want to enable the
digitization of all the
physical items that people
typically carry
within their wallet.
MIHAI IONESCU: So I will show
you now a slide which shows--
PENG YING: Yeah, there's
a lot of stuff.
MIHAI IONESCU: Lots of stuff
that actually does not fit in
your wallet.
You don't want to have all that
stuff in your wallet.
You need like five pockets
to keep all that.
PENG YING: Yeah.
I wear cargo shorts, and
it works for me.
MIHAI IONESCU: Or [INAUDIBLE].
So yes please, digitize.
PENG YING: So before, what we
did was we allowed you to save
payment cards and offers
into your Wallet.
And that was kind
of restrictive.
So at I/O, what we did
was we announced the
Wallet Objects API.
And this is one step towards
adding additional things and
being able to save additional
things into Google Wallet.
At I/O, we had two sessions
covering the
Wallet Objects API.
The first session was more of a
general session that covered
what are the pain points that
consumers typically encounter
today, and what are solutions
for those pain points.
The second session was a
technical deep dive session on
how to integrate the Google
Wallet Objects API.
MIHAI IONESCU: So it sounds
very interesting.
Let's go through them
one by one.
So the first session was
the overall session.
Let's talk about that
one a little bit.
PENG YING: Yeah.
So I think in everyday usage
of loyalty cards or offers,
there's a lot of friction
that occurs.
For example, on average, each
household has something like
18 loyalty cards.
But I'm pretty sure
that none of us
carry around that amount.
MIHAI IONESCU: Yep, they're
stuck in a drawer.
PENG YING: Yeah.
My cousin gave me a gift
card for Bed, Bath,
and Beyond for Christmas.
And it's just stuck in
a drawer somewhere.
I go to Bed, Bath, and Beyond,
but the card is never with me.
I think that's a problem that
a lot of people encounter.
And I have a Safeway card and
everything, but all of that
stuff stays at home.
And sometimes I forget
to enter in stuff.
So I think that's one of the
problems that we're trying to
solve for consumers.
These things that we probably
want to carry around but we
don't because it's a hassle.
One thing that everybody
does carry around,
though, is their phone.
It's already a camera.
It's already a communication
device.
It's already an MP3 player,
so why not add just add
a little bit more?
MIHAI IONESCU: It's
a computer.
PENG YING: Yeah, just add
a little bit more
functionality to it.
And the solution that we came
up with-- well, the solution
that we came up with before
was Wallet Objects.
And we're going to append
the Wallet Objects API.
So with it, developers can
define the objects that users
can store, and then users can
then save these objects to
their Google Wallet.
In addition to simplifying
things for the user, we're
also enabling a bunch of new
opportunities for the merchant.
We're enabling real-time updates
and geo-fencing for
each of these Wallet Objects.
So imagine that I'm shopping in
Union Square or something.
I'm kind of thirsty, and
my phone buzzes.
It reminds me that I have $10
saved at a store, let's say
Starbucks, for example.
Its geo-fencer knows that, hey,
there's a Starbucks around.
Hey, you have $10 saved here.
And it tells me that, reminds
me to go there.
So then I go to Starbucks.
I get my black coffee.
I'm not a big sugar and
cream kind of person.
MIHAI IONESCU: And you're
doubly happy.
PENG YING: Yeah, I'm
MIHAI IONESCU: You get
a coffee, and you
didn't spend any money.
You had a coupon.
PENG YING: Yeah, it reminded me
that I had a coupon for it.
But let's say that this coffee
is actually my 30th star.
And I think some people are
familiar with the Starbucks
rewards program.
But after you purchase 30
coffees, it upgrades you to
the next tier.
And then once I get upgraded
to the next tier, it
automatically notifies me
within the Google Wallet
application.
So that kind of engagement
and reminder mechanism is
something that we're trying
to provide as value to the
merchant and to the consumer.
Also, as a merchant, imagine
that I could have a Save to
Wallet button for offers on some
sort of ads on my site.
So now, when these things are
redeemed offline, I can kind
of track my online ad spend
to my offline conversions.
I think that being able to track
that is something that
could be really valuable
to merchants.
MIHAI IONESCU: It's
absolutely, yeah.
PENG YING: And what we're going
to show right now on the
screen is the consumer
sign-up experience.
Another benefit that we're
providing for merchants and
consumers is the ability
to instantly sign up.
So all of these consumers
have their information
stored in the cloud.
Why do they need to refill it in
every time they sign up for
a new loyalty program?
MIHAI IONESCU: Again, big
problem in general and in
particular on mobile devices.
PENG YING: Yeah.
A lot of pain points, right?
So we're trying to simplify that
by doing something like
instant sign-up.
Hey, I'm interested in signing
up for this loyalty program.
Hey, use my Google credentials
to fill it out.
And then boom, you're done.
You have your new loyalty card,
and you're now a member
of that program.
MIHAI IONESCU: Nice.
Design it with the consumer
in mind, and then--
PENG YING: Both parties.
There has to be value
to both parties for
anything to get adoption.
MIHAI IONESCU: So where can
developers start using it?
Is it available?
PENG YING: Well, the Wallet
Objects API right now is
currently private
for partners.
But we'll have a URL later that
we're going to show in a
little bit.
So if you're interested in
signing up for the Wallet
Objects API, it's at
google.com/walle
t/business/loyalty.
And I'm currently working on the
docs right now, so we will
get that out as soon
as possible.
MIHAI IONESCU: Another
easy to remember URL,
wallet/business/loyalty.
PENG YING: You can just pause
the YouTube stream, right?
Yeah--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
MIHAI IONESCU: Sign up form,
and we can get back to you
with more information how to get
your hands on the API and
start putting your loyalty
program or other kind of
digitized information
on there.
PENG YING: So if you're
interested in--
so for more information about
the Wallet Objects API or the
Wallet Objects platform and then
how we're envisioning it
and what pain points we're
trying to solve and the
general overview of it, check
out the "Introducing Wallet
Objects" session.
We also have a second session.
MIHAI IONESCU: So definitely we
just give a quick overview
and try to entice you a little
bit, get you more interested.
But the session has a lot of
information and definitely
worth watching.
And then the second session
you mentioned, which is
"Redefining Loyalty in
the Mobile Age."
PENG YING: Yeah.
So--
MIHAI IONESCU: Go into
more detail there.
PENG YING: The reason why
everything's loyalty and
offers is because we're
starting off
with two major verticals.
It's kind of the niche
approach, where we're
targeting the main pain points
that users encounter, which
are loyalty and offers.
So the session is about kind of
a technical deep dive, and
how do you integrate Wallet
Objects API for loyalty.
The same API is appable across
almost all the verticals that
Wallet Objects API supports.
And at its core, it's
an OAuth REST API.
So how the user uses it is you
would create a Wallet object.
The user then saves this Wallet
object to their wallet.
And then you can get a list of
the Wallet objects that users
have saved that you own.
And then you use the REST API
mechanisms to update it and
modify it and engage with
your consumers.
Everything that you update and
that you modify gets pushed to
your users in real time.
During the session, we also
talk about the JSON
representation of
these objects.
And if you're interested in
all these nitty gritty
details, check out the
"Redefining Loyalty in the
Mobile Age" presentation.
We'll probably also
have a GDL to do a
technical deep dive later.
Well, when the docs
are done, a little
bit later this quarter.
MIHAI IONESCU: Yeah.
We have a lot more stuff to talk
about, so stay tuned to
this channel.
All right, so great.
We covered the two major themes
at I/O, the Instant Buy
launch, improving the mobile
purchasing experience, and the
Wallet Objects platform launch,
digitizing your entire
world and putting it in the
cloud, in your digital wallet.
NASIR KHAN: Doing that,
you took a lot of pain
away from the users.
MIHAI IONESCU: Yes, and making
users happy along the way and
making it simpler for merchants
to make money and
improve conversion rates
in both cases.
So before wrapping up, let's
talk a little bit about the
Developer Sandbox at I/O, since
we're on the I/O topic.
So we met a lot of developers,
got a lot of great feedback.
Partners showcased their
latest apps.
PENG YING: Yeah.
Show them some pictures from--
MIHAI IONESCU: Yeah, pictures.
All right.
This is a picture [INAUDIBLE].
PENG YING: That looks
really busy.
MIHAI IONESCU: That was busy.
That was the Wallet
Developer Sandbox.
And if you look carefully,
maybe you
see some of us there.
And some of the partners Nasir
mentioned in the slides were
also Sandbox partners and
showcased their apps.
And we also had something very
interesting, like a prototype
interactive store that
you worked on, Peng.
Can you talk a little
bit about it?
PENG YING: Sure.
So we wanted something kind of
to inspire developers and get
them to think about things that
they could do with the
Instant Buy API.
And the best way to do that is
with something that is really
like, wow, like what kind of
purchase experience can you do
with this API that allows you
to purchase physical goods
really easily on a
mobile device?
And we kind of got some
inspiration from Tesco.
What we did was we built
a Google concept store.
And with the store, what
you're doing is you're
browsing items.
You can actually show
the next slide.
MIHAI IONESCU: Yeah, it's the
big screen, the vertical
screen on the right.
And we have another
picture of it.
And yay, this is Nagesh.
PENG YING: Yeah, this
guy is Nagesh.
He's also on our team.
And then we'll actually
be talking about this.
We'll be deep diving into
what we did next week--
or not next week, during
the next GDL.
But for now, I can give you a
quick overview of what it is
and why it's cool and what we
were hoping to accomplish.
MIHAI IONESCU: What is
he buying there?
PENG YING: That is an
Android plushie.
MIHAI IONESCU: A
fluffy android.
PENG YING: So the idea is that
it's an interactive display,
or an interactive touchscreen.
You can have all of your store's
inventory in a single
interactive display.
The user can pan through it.
And then once they tap
on the item, they
can find more details.
In the middle is actually
a 360 swivel.
So you get a 360 degree view of
the item that the user is
interested in.
And to purchase, what a user
can do is they can take out
their phone, they can scan the
QR codes, which adds the item
to their cart on the phone.
And using the Instant
Buy API, they can
purchase with a few clicks.
Fulfillment wasn't handled in
our concept demo, but you
could easily handle it with a
same-day delivery service.
So imagine something like oh,
the store is closed, but you
have this within the
window display.
A user could be walking by, like
maybe they see a shirt
that they like or something
that catches their fancy.
They check it out.
They interact with it.
It's like a real kind of
touching experience, in-person
experience, branded
experience.
They purchase it, and
then it's delivered
later to their house.
So that's kind of the showcase
that we wanted to make to
inspire developers and get them
thinking about hey, now
that purchasing physical goods
on the phone is so simple,
what can we do with it?
So in the next GDL, what we'll
be doing is talking about how
we built it.
We're also looking to open
source as much of the code as
we can so that anybody
can build
these interactive displays.
MIHAI IONESCU: A lot of this
looks like the real thing,
especially with the 3D swivel.
You can see the item
from all angles.
PENG YING: It's pretty cool.
MIHAI IONESCU: And let's say
you're at Costco, and
something is not available
there.
You just go--
PENG YING: Get it delivered
to your house.
MIHAI IONESCU: And yep,
buy it, and that's it.
PENG YING: Or you could put this
at the bus station, or--
NASIR KHAN: Kiosk
at the airport.
You could just buy things and
pick it up on the way.
PENG YING: Get it delivered to
your house or something.
MIHAI IONESCU: You could do it
before visiting the store and
just pick it up there.
Awesome.
Looking forward to
the session.
So that's it.
We did a quick tour and recap
of the Wallet sessions at
Google I/O. And again, thank you
for joining us, and thanks
to all the developers who
attended Google I/O and
visited the Sandbox, came
and talked with us.
We'll be back in a couple of
weeks with some more exciting
sessions, including the
interactive source session.
So until then, bye.
NASIR KHAN: Bye.
PENG YING: See you guys.
[MUSIC PLAYING]